foreign
for our daily cancellation today I feel
I must say something about the major
controversy that erupted last week
involving a country singer and I'm not
talking about Jason Aldean I'm talking
about Miranda Lambert who ignited a
Fierce and important debate when she
made the decision to stop in the middle
of her concert in Las Vegas to lecture
some fans in the front row who were
taking selfies if you haven't seen this
clip yet here it is
um
[Music]
I'm gonna stop right here for a sec
Danny I'm sorry
these girls are worried about their
selfie you're not listening to the song
it's pissing me off a little bit
[Applause]
we're here
oh
yeah
shall we start again
foreign
so apparently these fans were busy
taking pictures of themselves instead of
watching the show and so Lambert decided
to shame them in front of thousands of
people a decision that many on social
media and in the media to cried as
excessive and bullying but one that I
fully and enthusiastically support and
I'll explain why in a moment but first
we have to get to the other side of the
story uh from the from the selfie
culprits themselves what do they have to
say for themselves well they were
interviewed about the traumatic incident
on Good Morning America and here's what
they had to say
Adela Kalin says she and her friends
were taking these pictures when Miranda
told them they should be paying
attention to the show instead of taking
photos she said these girls are more
interested in taking selfies
and then she said sit down I thought I
feel like I'm being back in school and
me and my friends did something that
annoyed the teacher and she scolded us
and she told us to sit down after the
incident at the 7 000 person venue
Planet Hollywood where Lambert is doing
her Las Vegas residency she restarted
the song from the beginning shall we
start again
everybody was having such a great time
we were we would stand up at times and
dance it was great energy but after that
happened it was just um it was not the
same a representative for the singer
telling ABC News overnight Lambert had
quote No statement to add experts saying
fans snapping pictures at concerts is
typically all a part of the show taking
photos at concerts seems to be like a
very normal occurrence but I do think
that as a performer these sorts of
incidents do happen all the time and it
seems like Miranda just took this a
little bit too personally
well I'm glad that we heard from the
experts the experts on phone usage at
concerts Good Morning America brought in
the license credentialed concert selfie
experts to give us the news that people
take selfies at concerts a lot we could
not have known this without them we we
needed their guidance and insight we
need the experts to help us navigate
through every facet of life and answer
every question no matter how seemingly
obvious and banal thank God for the
experts all hail the experts trust the
experts trust in them
God be with them
but this still leaves the question about
whether Miranda Lambert was right to
publicly scald a group of women for
taking a few selfies and the answer is
that yes she was it is about time that
somebody in a position of influence so
however mild that influence may be
stands up and speaks out against the
selfie Scourge that has gripped hold of
our society for decades now
has become so endemic so inherent that
it seems pointless to complain about it
but the pointlessness of a complaint has
never stopped me before and it won't now
you do not need to take a picture of
every single thing you experience in
your life you really don't I promise you
you do not need documentation of every
moment you especially do not need
documentation of yourself experiencing
every moment
see I've never understood the motivation
here which is why I never take selfies
unless someone stops me in public and
asks for one and even then I only do it
because I'm afraid that if I refuse
they'll call up TMZ and complain about
how rude Matt Walsh is at which point
TMZ will respond wait who is Matt Walsh
and that will make the whole thing even
more embarrassing so I just take the
picture but the point is that
selfies selfies are pointless millions
of people
carry around phones stocked with
hundreds of pictures of their own faces
just think about that for a moment and
do any of them actually go back and
scroll through those pictures
reminiscing about how their faces looked
yep that's my face at Disney World
oh there's my face at Applebee's I
remember that
I'll never forget the time that my face
went to Applebee's and wow there's my
face at Grandma's funeral
is that what people do our friends over
at genucel sold out of their Dark Spot
Corrector and our listeners have been
begging for a restock well I have great
news just in time for the summer it's
back in stock uh well it's August now
but I mean just in time for the summer
the last part of Summer anyway gender
cell's famous dark spot director has not
won but three Cutting Edge ingredients
and goes to work fast to Target sunspots
dark spots liver spots and even old
discoloration both on your face and your
hands you can now enjoy your summer sun
Beach and barbecues without embarrassing
spots join yourself's most popular
package also features this uh their
summer Essentials like the best-selling
Ultra retinol moisturizer with a
powerful retinal alternative for safe
use in the sun you'll be amazed at how
quickly you'll see results or 100 of
your money back guaranteed go to
jennycell.com Walsh right now to get
your dark spot corrector and the genucel
most popular package that's
geniusell.com Walsh right now and save
over 70 off Jenny cell's most popular
package all orders will include a
mystery luxury gift while supplies last
geniusell.com Walsh now
it's clear that the left is giving up
their morals in any Common Sense there's
no better time than to build a daily
habit of prayer meditation building a
habit of prayer can help you cultivate
an attitude of gratitude focusing on
what you're thankful for can increase
positive emotions and improve overall
well-being hello is the number one
Christian Prayer app in the U.S it's
helped me maintain a daily prayer
routine and can help you to download the
app for free at hello.com Matt Walsh you
can set prayer reminders track your
progress along the way not sure where to
start we'll check out father Mike
schmitz's Bible in a year podcast for
brief daily Bible reading reflect and
Reflections or you can pray alongside
Mark Wahlberg Jim Caviezel and even some
world-class athletes with Halo
you can customize a personal prayer plan
that works for you listen wherever you
are with downloadable offline sessions
using hello to connect with others who
share your beliefs and values can
provide a sense of belonging support and
Foster a sense of community as well
ultimately we'll learn how we can become
better individuals in spite of today's
broken World As We strive to become more
christ-like in our daily lives through
prayer fasting and giving download Hello
at hello.com Matt Walsh and get an
exclusive three months free that's three
months absolutely free at hello.com Matt
Walsh of course I realize that they
aren't primarily taking pictures in
order to store them away as keepsakes
but rather to post them on social media
so that everyone else can see but that's
even more pointless
okay because nobody cares that you were
at a Miranda Lambert concert
but if anyone does care for some reason
they probably want to see a picture of
Miranda Lambert up on stage they don't
need to see you in the stands
recently I you know I saw a picture of a
guy the guy posted of himself on
vacation and on social media and he was
uh he was visiting the pyramids in Egypt
and the picture was a selfie with a
pyramid in the background
posted to social media for all to enjoy
but if the rest of us want to see a
picture from your vacation at all and we
don't we'd rather just see the pyramids
without your face crowding up the frame
how egotistical do you have to be to
think that these magnificent three
thousand year old structures can be
improved by adding your face to them
see this is the real tragedy of selfie
culture it encourages you to experience
life with your back turn to it putting
yourself at the center of something that
you aren't even paying attention to
our obsession with documenting
everything we do and worse documenting
ourselves doing it rather than
documenting the thing itself
has ironically made it so that we miss
out on the very things we're documenting
this is a familiar observation even
cliched but it's true we are so obsessed
with creating digital proof that we were
there that we aren't really there at all
we need to learn how to Simply occupy
the space that we are standing in right
existing in and absorbing each present
moment as it comes personally I would
never go to a Miranda Lambert concert
but but but if you do go if you buy the
tickets if you spend the money too much
money to have that experience then have
that experience be there for it which
means not being on your phone now you
might argue that taking one quick selfie
while while a pointless Act
is not going to significantly intrude on
your or anyone else's ability to enjoy
the moment
but we all know that these girls we're
not taking one quick selfie no that
doesn't exist especially for women like
that they were taking a series of shots
from different angles they were posting
an Instagram they were doing little
videos for tick tock uh then they were
taking more selfies and on and on and on
I mean we all know I wasn't there but I
know just from looking at that woman I
listened to her speak for five seconds
that that's the way it went
even if I'm wrong okay even if it was
just one brief selfie incident I would
still defend Lambert's response because
what you have to understand
is that some of us have grown exhausted
with all of this with the fact that
people can't look up from their phones
with the constant need to document and
take pictures and videos and so we React
to what some some might consider
disproportionate ways when somebody
pulls out a phone or takes a picture my
wife will tell you that I have only
grown more and more resistant to being
involved in any picture or selfie
activity uh as time has gone on if we go
on vacation we go anywhere and she pulls
out the fog we gotta take a picture I'm
very resistant and only more so as time
goes on it's not that I flat out refuse
to be in a picture or even to take one
on occasion in fact I just took a
picture a few days ago of a nice bass
that I caught was probably about six
pounds maybe I'll be arguably seven
pounds it was it was you know it was
probably about 23 inches but it was a
fat uh a fish it was a great great fish
anyway obviously uh I'm gonna get a
picture of that actually most of the
pictures in my phone are not photos of
my own face but are photos of various
fish that I've caught and that's
different
because I need documentation of the
behemoths that I'm landing or else
nobody will believe me
anyway aside from these exceptions
generally I'm resistant to posing for
pictures of selfies much to my wife
Chagrin but my point to her is that we
don't need photographic evidence of
every moment it is it is good enough
that we live those moments we immerse
ourselves in those moments and hold the
memories in our hearts
as people have always done we don't need
any more selfies nobody does
we need to put down the phone turn our
gaze back upon this great wild world
and these wonderful experiences that are
so much larger than a screen if only we
would look up and see it
and yes I will give this whole speech to
my wife rather than stop for five
seconds to take a picture
because someone has to take a stand
and I'm glad to see that I'm not totally
alone which is why Miranda Lambert
certainly is not canceled today instead
it is the Perpetual selfie takers who
are with a Vengeance today canceled hey
YouTube thanks for listening to the show
if you'd like access to my full show
with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there